[Music]
on this thursday night facing up to
alberta's crisis
the premier finally admits mistakes
reverses course and reimposes
restrictions we must deal with the
reality that we are facing we cannot
wish it away as more albertans die can
jason kenny survive politically
what's riding on the 905 the vast and
volatile swath of voters in ontario
the paternity results are in did
canada's former top soldier father a
child with a subordinate a global news
exclusive and pushed to the brink it was
not uncommon that i would see someone
who was dying and an end of life in the
hallway we take you inside brampton's
only hospital
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
we are in brampton ontario tonight a
rapidly growing city that's in a part of
the province all the federal parties
covet not only are there millions of
potential votes in this region it's
politically volatile many voters switch
parties in 2011 people here helped elect
a tory majority and then in 2015 they
swung left helping justin trudeau win
his majority
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight in alberta where
premier jason kenney is finally dealing
with a covid 19 crisis that he's ignored
and denied for months in july kenny
declared the pandemic over removed
public health restrictions and pretty
well disappeared from view despite
multiple warnings the fourth wave was
coming while now it has hit with deadly
force ten more deaths were reported in
alberta today 896 people are now in the
hospital 222 of them are in intensive
care
alberta health services announced today
it is cancelling all scheduled surgeries
in that province and ontario has offered
to accept icu patients from alberta
much of this was preventable last night
premier kenny apologized for moving too
quickly to declare the pandemic over but
he didn't apologize for lifting almost
all the public health restrictions in
early july
now those restrictions are back a
vaccine passport system is being put in
place and at certain more albertans will
die before those things have an impact
heather urex west has our top story
tonight
11 weeks after removing all public
health restrictions alberta's open
summer has come to an abrupt end we may
run out of staffed intensive care beds
within the next 10 days facing a crisis
in alberta hospitals that could no
longer be ignored the premier introduced
broad new public health measures
wednesday alberta will no longer be wide
open this fall there are new
restrictions on indoor social gatherings
and for businesses unless they opt into
the restriction exemption program
alberta's version of the vaccine
passport the premier offered an apology
of sorts i apologize for
having
embraced the uh
public shift from pandemic to endemic
which was clearly premature that don't
apologize for having lifted public
health restrictions in our open for
summer plan but a summer without any
restrictions has led alberta into a
crisis doctors have been trying to
prevent
former alberta chief medical officer of
health dr james talbot says even with
these measures it's likely alberta
doctors will have to implement critical
care triage protocols ultimately
deciding who will live and die the
people who are going to have to make
those decisions are going to be haunted
by them for the rest of their lives
because they're going to have to face up
with two things to do things one they
had to make the choice and two was
completely preventable he says if those
in power had been listening one of the
truly
troubling things that happened in the
province was that the premier and some
of his closest advisors were publicly
sneering at albertans who were trying to
raise issues of public health a senior
staff member in the premier's office
tweeted in early june the pandemic is
ending accept it now on the brink of a
health care disaster the alberta
government has accepted that was wrong
heather urex west global news calgary
the pandemic is not over and what's
happening in alberta puts it front and
center days before the federal election
abigail beeman is traveling with the
liberal campaign abigail
donna justin trudeau called the
situation in alberta heartbreaking and
while he held back from directly
slamming premier jason kenney he used
the opportunity to take swipes at aaron
o'toole and broadly conservative
government's handling of the pandemic
and that's at the heart of the choice
canadians need to make in this election
because just a few days ago mr o'toole
was
still applauding
mr kenny
for his management of the pandemic
trudeau said he reached out to the clerk
of the privy council to talk about
supports for alberta and he said
ventilators are now on the way to the
province and ottawa will be there to
help trudeau was also asked about his
contradictory message he literally tells
people to vote liberal to quote end the
pandemic at the same time as saying it's
not his job to interfere with the
provinces and their decisions the
closest trudeau came to criticizing
alberta directly was to say if they had
signed on to vaccine passports sooner
things might be better right now donna
all right abigail in quebec thank you
well the liberals have tried to link
jason kennedy to federal conservative
leader aaron o'toole who has praised
kenny's handling of the pandemic and are
hoping to capitalize on the anger in
alberta here's part of an ad from the
liberal candidate in calgary skyview
premier kenny has navigated this covid19
pandemic far better than the federal
government has
and when it comes to getting our country
back on track
the federal conservatives can learn a
lot
from our ucp
cousin
our michael couture is with the
conservatives mike how is aaron o'toole
handling this
donna earlier today erin o'toole
repeatedly refused to comment on how
alberta premier jason kenney is handling
the covet 19 situation in his province
during his press conference at a curling
rink he slid around multiple questions
about how as recently as last sunday the
federal conservative leader praised his
provincial counterparts management of
the pandemic despite kenny now admitting
he got it wrong as he declared a public
health emergency wednesday o'toole would
only say he supports province's efforts
to try and fight covet 19 each time
turning it back to a criticism of
liberal leader justin trudeau and his
management of the pandemic
donna
all right mike lacouture in truro nova
scotia thanks well covet cases are
rising fast in saskatchewan too starting
tomorrow masks will be mandatory in all
indoor public spaces and a proof of
vaccination policy starts october 1st
people will have to show they are
immunized or show a recent negative test
it will apply to all non-essential
businesses and event venues
if you aren't vaccinated and living in
saskatchewan
it's now time to get your shot
the vast majority of saskatchewan people
that have done the right thing
quite frankly they are tired of those
that have chose not to
saskatchewan is the last province in
western canada to implement a version of
a vaccine passport
we are in brampton where the medical
officer of health for this region warned
today more people will die of covid19
here unless vaccinations increase 77
percent of eligible people in peel
region have had both doses he wants that
to rise to 90 percent now politically
brampton and the region around here is
packed with voters who aren't loyal to
any particular party they are vote
switchers our chief political
correspondent david aiken explains why
that makes this fertile ground for all
the parties david
donna let me show you the 905 the region
we're talking about it's a horseshoe
shaped region around toronto 30 seats
most of them are liberal red but beyond
the border of the 905 a solid wall of
conservative blue
and that is the choice in the 905 it
really is either liberals here in
oakville you've knocked on thousands and
thousands of doors and made thousands
more phone calls
keep it up
or conservatives far too many people
across the region are trapped in
gridlock every day
far too many people
especially young people are priced out
of the housing market no other party has
ever had success in the region
ed broadband is the only new democrat to
win here in the last 60 years now while
the 25 seats in toronto are usually
reliably liberal
and the 34 seats in alberta are reliably
conservative the 30 ridings in the 905
have often changed hands over the years
that electoral volatility combined with
the sheer number of seats in the region
has given the 905 an outsize influence
on our national politics and that's why
we're going to pay so much attention to
this region on election night and
specifically to the writings on the
borders writings like milton where in
2019 liberal olympic kayaker adam
vancouver and beat conservative lisa
rape or also on the northern border near
vaughan two ridings home to the largest
concentration of italian canadian voters
or were you or donna in brampton five
ridings huge south asian population all
went conservative in 2011 when stephen
harper won his majority all snap back
red to justin trudeau when he won in
2019. one final tidbit about the 905 and
the gta there's never been a prime
minister in our history to hold any one
of these ridings so if the mp for durham
aaron o'toole can win this thing well
that'll be a first donna
okay lots of play there david aiken in
ottawa thanks the cost of housing is a
big issue here as it is in so many
places across the country the average
cost of a home in the gta is more than a
million dollars ndp leader jagmeet singh
is in the region today making his case
on how he'd solve the problem robin gill
is with the ndp in the last days of the
campaign robin
donna while in the gta the ndp leader is
hammering away at the affordable housing
crisis given that toronto is one of the
most expensive real estate markets in
the country
the ntp leader wants to stop the
flipping of homes and big developers
making big profits it's the same message
he's been hitting at since the start of
the election we've got to get that
pressure out of the market get that big
money out of the market and we've got
two ways to do that one of foreign
buyers tax second change the capital
gains that would discourage
the existing incentive in property
flipping singh insists that there will
be no tax on primary residences despite
the skyrocketing prices in this country
okay robin in toronto thank you we take
you inside brampton's only hospital
coming up how health workers already
pushed to the brink before the pandemic
are struggling now
you're looking at the credit river here
in brampton we are on the treaty lands
of the mississaugas of the credit
we'll be right back
brampton ontario is home to about 600
000 people it is the ninth largest city
in canada home to lots of essential
workers shift workers and new immigrants
and there is only one hospital brampton
civic hospital was already bursting at
the seams before the pandemic hit now
it's at the breaking point
jeff semple takes us inside
staff at brampton civic hospital are
constantly on the move
this emergency physician is juggling 16
patients only a couple of whom have
covid19
the usual illness that we saw
dip during the pandemic those illnesses
are coming back
patients particularly children arriving
with flu-like illness
while others like this 50-year-old woman
with an advanced lung infection avoided
coming to hospital during the pandemic
she's now rushed to the icu
we're seeing volumes there like we've
never seen really in history actually
and within the icu i think we're
starting to see those covet cases rise
this hospital was one of the hardest hit
by the first waves of the pandemic the
region home to a large number of
immigrants and essential workers had
ontario's most covid cases per capita
and in a city the size of vancouver more
than 600 000 residents this is the only
hospital
even prior to the pandemic brampton
civic was one of the busiest hospitals
in ontario its average hospital
occupancy before covet 19 was nearly 109
percent we knew we had to do something
this brampton city councilor moved a
motion last year days before canada's
first confirmed case of covid 19 to
declare a health care emergency mr mayor
the motion carries unanimously we were
so stretched and our capacity was so
overwhelmed
and kovit has only
expanded that
tenfold brampton is one of canada's
fastest growing cities but healthcare
funding has failed to keep pace when the
pandemic hit the hospital found itself
caring for the most covid patients with
the fewest hospital beds it was not
uncommon that i would see someone who
was dying an end of life in the hallway
this doctor left the hospital in april
after 15 years even prior to the
pandemic staff treated more than 4 000
patients a year in hospital hallways
before elections politicians i remember
would come to our hospital and hold
press conferences about ending hallway
medicine but the action
never really happened and the story of
brampton i feel is largely the story of
many people who are new immigrants to
canada who faced inequities in the
health care system which is grossly
underfunded
last spring ontario's premier doug ford
announced a hospital expansion that will
include 250 new hospital beds and a
second emergency department for brampton
but donna construction on that not
expected to begin until the year 2023
and even with those additions brampton
will remain well below the provincial
average when it comes to hospital beds
per capita so many promises made and not
kept jeff simple thanks
still ahead claims by a former top
soldier accused of sexual misconduct
don't pass a paternity test
global news has learned exclusive new
details about the allegations of sexual
misconduct facing former chief of the
defense staff retired general jonathan
vance dna testing shared with global
news found advance all but certainly
fathered a child with major kelly
brennan years after he said their
relationship had ended our ottawa bureau
chief mercedes stevenson has the
exclusive story
he fathered two children with me that's
major kelly brennan disclosing for the
first time publicly a belief she's held
privately for years global news has
obtained the results of two paternity
tests taken by former chief of the
defense staff jonathan vance and two of
brennan's children one test found the
probability vance fathered the child is
99.99991
that contradicts vance's past statements
that his sexual relationship with
brennan ended in 2001 when both were
still posted to canadian forces base
gagetown in new brunswick nothing since
then
since gagetown no you're sure
you 100 sure john
are you 100 sure
yes
paternity testing for a second child
ruled out vance as being the father in
that case global news is not disclosing
the names or ages of the children to
protect their identities but both were
born after 2001. neither vance nor his
lawyer responded to multiple attempts by
global news to seek comment for this
story but we did ask vance in february
about the paternity allegations so
you're not father
i am not
you're not
father
i don't even know who these people are
vance has denied all allegations of
inappropriate behavior military police
opened an investigation into the
allegations of sexual misconduct made by
two subordinate women who came forward
about vance to global news vance cannot
be tried for any military charges
related to sexual misconduct because his
rank prevents him from being prosecuted
in a military court it is absolutely
unacceptable
that because of rank
certain people be exempt
from the law experts say there is also a
potential national security concern
secrets could be exploited for blackmail
by enemy foreign powers vance has been
charged with obstructing justice and is
scheduled to appear in court friday
mercedes stephenson global news ottawa
a brampton mother's loss in the pandemic
up next could her son's death have been
prevented
one of canada's biggest warehouse and
distribution hubs is here in brampton
ontario and during the pandemic
thousands of essential workers in peel
region kept essentials moving one of
those people was harman deep singh he
was 36 he died in brampton civic
hospital of covet 19. his family says he
fell through the cracks and community
advocates say his death was preventable
farah nasser has his story
manmeet oberoi grieves for her son
harman deep singh it's his loss and he
was not ready for it the canadian tire
team leader died in may after a short
battle with covid19 he was just 36 years
old i don't know how harmandi must have
felt the night he spent
in the er
right
and
the final breath that he took
oberoi her husband and their son tested
positive for coveted 19 in april they
were vaccinated but harmon deep didn't
yet qualify asthmatic with worsening
symptoms he went to brampton civic
hospital obroy says her son was turned
away twice isolate yourself take tylenol
golden flu
after
two days he really felt bad he spent his
five to six hours in the er the first
thing nurse told us there are so many
people before him don't know how many
going to die discharged with puffers and
anxiety medication harmadeep died 30
hours later if brampton had more
hospitals more hospital beds you think
your son could possibly still be alive
the hospital isn't commenting citing
patient privacy but in a statement says
they're undertaking a care review when
obroy and her family fell ill brampton's
coven 19 test positivity reached above
20 percent double the province's rate of
10.5 this workers advocate says
thousands of essential employees like
harman veep put their lives in danger
daily we had some of the biggest
workplace outbreaks here
and instead of getting services that we
needed we were being blamed for for
having high cases is it fair to say that
you think brampton was left behind 100
and i think it's been left behind for
decades now
we are a huge racialized community and i
think that has a lot to do with it and
so there are so many people here that
can't access proper rights or services
or programs
in one of the communities hardest hit
areas samarith core sees inequality
firsthand a lot of people
did have a hit towards brampton fearing
another lockdown she worries her
community will be overlooked yet again
they are living by hand hand to mouth
they can't just work from home given
heightened risk factors in communities
like brampton obroy feels those in power
federally should have done more to
respond sooner they know what's going on
you know if they don't know then they
don't deserve to be in the government
they don't deserve to be our leaders
the day her son died was the same day he
would have qualified for his first dose
this election that's never far from her
thoughts far nasser global news brampton
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna freeze and we leave
you tonight with more images from
brampton an incredibly diverse city
people from at least 170 different
cultures have settled here thanks for
watching i'll see you again on monday
we'll have extensive coverage on
election night here on global for now
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]